okay i sued the Margaret Bruce returning
officer the Emerald westboro
constituency declare that the total
number of votes given to each candidate
was as follows black hat Scottish Green
Party 1140
Robert my Scottish Liberal Democrats
18,000 168
de kami Scottish Labour Party 6425
things George Grant Gordon auto UK
Independence Party 1015 Patterson
Lindsay Sheila Scottish Conservative in
unionist 6732 Thomson Michelle Rona
Scottish National Party 21,000
aight i therefore can public notice that
michelle thompson is julie elected as
Member of Parliament
the total number of votes cast across
the end robust baroque constituency or
at fifty 4907 the total number of ballot
papers rejected was 49 which is 0.09
percent the turnout for the constituency
was seventy six point five six percent
thank you very much
in the interest of time is being
extraordinary long day and long evening
for all of us I shall be brief so as is
traditional I would like to thank the
returning officer the police and all the
people who work so hard to ensure a
Tegra came is run efficiently I'd also
like to thank my fellow candidates and
note the mutual respect shown by the
mall shooting a long and hard fought
campaign I'm humane especially my
predecessor microcar to has worked hard
for this constituency for the last five
years in a high so cones i also find my
campaign team who be singularly
committed as well as a part of the
inexhaustible during the last few months
you have all worked so hard for our
shared success and I want you all to
know how grateful I am for the iris days
and weeks you've put in there are many
people to find and I believe I have the
best campaign team in Scotland I
especially like to highlight my campaign
manager Tony brain and my agent in front
I also need to find my family
particularly my husband Peter who
continues to be a support at all times
but most of all I find the waters of
Emeril West for placing their trust in
me to be a strong voice at Westminster
on their behalf when the you voted SNP
or not and whatever your views are on
Scotland's future I will seek to
represent everyone in this constituency
to the best of my ability it's just what
microcosm of Scotland with this diverse
demographic and
rich seam of interesting people many of
whom I met during the last few months
young families business people the
unemployed hi pliers are just ordinary
folk going about their daily lives as
are groupable a 10pm he's arrived at
Westminster we will carry with us our
manifesto commitments our long-held
commitment to social justice our
protection of the NHS and the delivery
of progressive policies for the man for
Scotland and for the whole of the UK we
want to see a decent living wage
investment in childcare and education
not in nuclear weapons me notice take
the shape of UK politics has changed no
longer will it simply shift achieve me
too dominant parties so as well as the
beginning this also marks an end the end
it must be the end of the austerity
agenda and relentless cuts to the
benefits of our most vulnerable people
and enter
Marty's we didn't elect and then into
freezing Scotland's voice Oh to
Westminster no we have the chance to
make sure our voices are heard and to
pursue a progressive path but the
benefice Scotland and the rest of the UK
it is a huge privilege to be standing
you know and I promise to do my best to
repeat the faith and trust you place to
me thank you